hi everyone
and welcome back to cs330 and uh today
we'll be talking about a graphical model
perspective on multitask and method
reinforcement learning
[Music]
yeah okay
um all right so the plan for the lecture
is as following uh first we'll go over
variation inference and i think chelsea
went over it a little bit already so
this will be
we'll go over it again to make sure that
you understand the intuition behind it
um then we will present a framework that
allows us to frame a control problem as
an inference problem in a specific
parabolic graphical model
then we'll apply variational inference
to that model
and then finally we'll get to the point
where we can derive a new meta
reinforcement learning algorithm using
all of that knowledge and applying
variational inference to slightly
different rational inference to a
graphical model
all right so uh a quick disclaimer
there will be quite a bit of math in
this lecture um and quite a bit of
derivations i want to go through all the
derivations in detail i'll skim through
them and try to give you the intuitions
all the derivations are there in the
slides so if you'd like to derive it
yourself or just check how it's derived
you can take a look at that
i will try to uh make sure that there
are some anchor points so even if you
get lost you still can kind of get back
to it and uh you know get the intuition
behind the ideas
um
and
if there are any questions uh i think
the best option is to raise your hand uh
rather than using the chat which can be
a little distracting so i would
encourage you to do that and i'll also
ask um
every now and then after every section
if there are any questions
another thing is that this is an active
research topic
there's a lot of development going on
in that
in that subfield so there might be more
questions than answers but that's one of
the reasons why this is this is quite
exciting
um
all right so let's start with um
why variational inference why should we
care about this
um so variational inference is a main
tool that helps us cope with latent
variable models so then the natural
question is what are latent variable
models
and to introduce this i will go through
a quick example
so here we plotted uh
some kind of data distribution right so
this is two-dimensional
data and here i color-coded it in a
certain way and this is just for your
convenience
but this is the data we get to see
and
you know looking at this data
it's not very conveniently distributed
it's not that you can easily fit a
gaussian to it and it will just work so
there might be some latent structure
that that might help us to model the
data better
so in particular we can look at that
color encoding
which suggests that
maybe there are three gaussians maybe
this is a mixture of three gaussians
so
if we if we kind of discover that fact
that there is some underlying structure
that there are three gaussians
that will not only help us to model the
data a little bit better but it would
also tell us a little bit more about the
structure of the data we see
so now if we use the fact that there are
three gaussians here we can write the
probability of a data point
as the sum over
additional latent variable z
so that latent variable here is a
discrete random variable it's a
categorical random variable that tells
us which cluster does the data belong to
right so it can only take values one two
or three it gives us the number of the
cluster
so now in order to compute the
probability of a data point what we can
do is we can sum over all the clusters
sum over z and
maybe i'll use the
laser pointer right here um sum over z
and we can take the probability of um of
the data belonging to a particular
gaussian to a particular cluster so
what's the probability of the data point
given that you are in a particular
regression so that would be for example
that one
times the prior probability of which
cluster the data is in
right
so to say a little bit more what that p
of z is um if we were to plot the
distribution it might look something
like that so it's a
discrete uh categorical
random variable that can be distributed
like this for instance and this just
tells us what's the probability of the
data point belonging to a specific
option this is the prior on that
all right so um i hope this is
relatively clear so how can we extend
this concept such that we don't just
operate on discrete number of clusters
or a latent variable that is a discrete
variable but instead we expand it to a
continuous variable
right
so let's try to do this so i'll change
the distribution a little bit so now our
distribution is over a variable that is
just one dimensional so we only have x
here and this is our probability
distribution p of x so it's a little
funky looking distribution and that's um
it's not very conveniently distributed
it's not just a gaussian or something
like this so
we need to represent it somehow
so now p of z instead of being a
distribution over a discrete random
variable would be a distribution over a
continuous random variable for example a
normal distribution right so this would
be a caption so that that p of z over
here this is the equivalent just in the
continuous world of that p of z that we
had over here
so now if we were to rewrite that
formula it would look very similar
but instead of summing over the discrete
number of clusters or discrete number of
values that the latent variable can take
we will be taking the integral over all
the
all the values of z
right that's what makes it a little
tricky so now what does that what's the
intuition behind it what what what does
it mean in practice
so if we were to sample a particular z
for example let's say that one right
here
that would correspond to
some kind of gaussian the same as you
know that z corresponded let's say to
gaussian number one over here
so that will get transformed to some
kind of gaussian p of x given z
right and that gaussian would look maybe
like this
now what that integral is doing
is
it's taking the it's integrating out z
so it's taking the integral over all
possible values of z
for example you know these are a few
samples and each one of them can be
mapped to a slightly different gaussian
for example something like that or
something like that
and they're right there could be right
next to each other sorry this is a
terrible picture but i hope you get the
idea
and uh if we integrate out z entirely we
should be able then to represent any
continuous distribution right we are
just integrating zl so we are
integrating over every single possible z
so it's kind of like creating a mixture
of gaussian where you have infinitely
many
infinitely many components
as opposed to just three components on
the left
all right so
going back to why this is useful
well so i think you've heard about the
variational output encoder
um so variational auto encoder is one
use case for this where
we can have our
data for example images and we want to
represent some kind we want to discover
some kind of latent structure in the
data
so what the variational out encoder
which is a latent variable model would
allow us to do is to map our images into
some latent space so two points in some
latent space that could be two points on
that gaussian
and then we can
interpolate through that latent space
and that interpolation would result in a
smooth interpolation in the image space
as well
right so we discovered some kind of
latent structure in the data and we can
then generate the data using that latent
structure
all right so this is a little bit about
latent variable models so
why are we talking about this in the
context of control so they're actually
very common in control and one
particular use case is a common filter
and common filter is uh something that
is
used very often in robotics to this day
to do things such as state estimation or
localization
and uh
it's a very popular approach that's
actually quite old it was discovered in
the in the in the 60s
um
and common filter hinges on a a model a
graphical model that looks more or less
like this it's a hidden markov model
where we observe some variables so
in this case we're observing for example
the measurements
right so for example your robot
has some kind of wider on it and based
on this it observes the world around it
and then common filter tells us how we
can estimate
the the state or the position of your
robot so these are the latent factors z
so this is one one possible use case of
latent variable models in control and
we'll learn about a few more
all right and then
we'll also talk about control as
inference and this is a slightly
different topic so
let me let me try to introduce it as
well why why this is why this is
important
and
this is a framework that allows us to
describe a stochastic optimal behavior
so what what do we mean by this so so
far our algorithms our reinforcement
learning algorithms the only thing they
were focusing on was to optimize the sum
of future rewards right so they're just
trying to be optimal
so what does that mean so for example if
we have an owner and a and a dog the dog
is the agent
if the dog if the owner is asking the
doctor come over
then and we observe the data
how the dog is coming to the owner it
would look some probably like that so we
will have a dog here we'll have the
owner here and then the owner is asking
the doctor to come over and let's say
the reward is the distance to the
negative distance to the owner and then
the only thing that our reinforcement
learning framework can explain right now
is the straight path and the perfect
optimal behavior because the agent is
only optimizing for the some of the
rewards
however we know that in the in the real
life
that can actually take a few different
paths and maybe it will look something
like that where maybe it will sniff
something on the side maybe it will get
distracted
and it won't be always perfect so it's
optimal but it's a little stochastic
right so that's also how we humans do
things we're not always
exactly perfect and we're not always
exactly optimizing some kind of reward
but we you kind of can get from our
movements what we're trying to do but
our behavior is a little bit stochastic
so the idea in control as inference is
that if we can describe that stochastic
optimal behavior through some model
and then transfer this to our agents
maybe our agents would behave a little
bit more like like we do and maybe it
will improve our our reinforcement
learning agents
and that turns out to be true to some
extent so we'll learn in the future
lectures on how uh the probabilistic
graphical model that we'll use to
describe control can help with better
exploration with hierarchical
reinforcement learning and skill
discovery
all right so this is a short intro to
the topic we'll jump into variational
inference now um are there any questions
all right looks like no questions so far
um
okay so let's talk about variational
inference
um
so variational inference is a tool that
allows us to deal with these latent
variable models and just to repeat
what's the problem with the formulation
that we have so far
well the problem is that so this p of z
this is just a simple normal
distribution it's a gaussian gaussians
are nice we know how to deal with them
this p of x given z it's also a gaussian
for example a gaussian right here
um that's relatively easy as well but
what's difficult what makes that entire
equation difficult is that integral over
a continuous variable that makes it
intractable so we need to somehow
get our z's but do it without the
integral and this is where variational
inference comes in where it can be
useful
all right so i'll go through this
relatively quickly
let's see how we can go about it so
um usually we will try to what we are
trying to do in supervised learning we
are trying to maximize likelihood of our
data
all right so here we are we have the i
data point i depict the index of the
data point we are uh having the id
assumption of our data and we are
multiplying the probabilities of our
data belonging to the model and we're
trying to maximize that and then we can
do this with log likelihood instead
since likelihood since logarithm is a
monotonic function
all right so so far so good
so let's now take the the log of p theta
of x i so the log probability of a
particular data point x i and let's
write it out according to our model so
according to our little integral right
here
all right
so let's move a little further
now we can multiply the entire equation
by one we can always do that and here we
take a particular version of one which
is some kind of distribution of z of our
latent variable we will call it q i of z
and
we will divide it by the same thing so
that that's just one
right now an important thing to note
here is that this could be any
distribution of z right we just picked
some q i of z it could be anything it
could be q of z given something it could
be just q of z
the options are endless here
right
so now what we can do is we can take
that q z and we have an integral of q i
of z dz which is the definition of the
expectation under q i z so this is what
we did right here we still have the log
and instead of the integral and the q i
of z in the numerator
we have the expectation
now we can apply jensen's inequality
which is a
simple inequality that tells us that a
logarithm of a log a logarithm of an
expectation is always greater equal than
the expectation of the log
right so we are not going to prove it
um
but
it basically looks like this and we can
actually derive what that bound is
and that's um
that's not that complicated i can
include it in the in the lecture notes
but uh
let's just keep going and see what we
get with this so right now we are
lower bounding our objective by
something that looks like the
expectation of the lock of that ratio
now we can split that ratio into two
different terms which we did down here
and we can split it even further and say
that
our log
p theta of x i is lower bounded by
something that looks like this by log of
p of x i given z under the expectation
of q i of z
minus the kl divergence between qi of z
so some kind of distribution that we
just made up
and the prior p of z
all right so this is a very quick
derivation
but let's just focus on the formula and
try to understand what what that means
all right so here i just i just copy
pasted that the final equation
um and just one quick note so
um
what we what we did here if we look at
this we said that i
is the
is the index of the data point so x i is
a particular data point in your data
so far we introduced q i of z
which is a distribution over z
that is specific to that particular data
point all right so we have q i of z here
and q y of z here
so what that means we'll have as many
distribution
q q of z distributions as we have data
points which is
you know in the era of deep learning
this is
a very very large number so we don't
don't necessarily want that
so instead what what we will do is we
will use so-called amortized variational
inference
which changes the distribution q
rather than it being q i of z q i of z
it becomes q of z given x i right so we
are free to choose whatever distribution
over z we like we chose that
distribution so that instead of having
many many distributions we just have one
distribution that tells us the z given
the current data point
and so this is a small modification
all right so let's take that formula and
let's try to understand the
um
the intuition behind it
and uh here one one last thing to note
is that we would have two different
parameters here we'll have parameters
for the
p for our p distribution and these will
call parameters theta these are the
parameters that um
given our z would tell us what would
produce the would tell us the
probability of the image
and we have parameters phi which are the
parameters of our variational
distribution q
all right and we can use that equation
we can maximize that variational lower
bound so-called to optimize for both for
both of these for
phi and theta
all right
so intuition
all right so what we build actually
looks
some like something like that we have
our input data point x i
then this gets transformed into some
kind of latent code using our
variational distribution right so we'll
have some kind of neural network that
takes that data point and then
transforms it into some lower
dimensional latent space z
all right and this is our q phi of z
given x i
so in other words this is encoding the
image into some kind of latent code z
right we can also call it the encoder
and then we have a the second part of
that equation which now takes that
takes that latent code samples from that
distribution takes its latent code and
produces the e-match all right so this
is now p theta of x i given z so this is
trying to decode that latent code back
into the image
right so this is again this is where
this is variational iot encoder where we
are first encoding the image
and then decoding
all right
so um
this is the equation this is the
variational lower bound that we just
derived that we have to maximize with
respect to both
theta and phi in order to to learn that
and usually for we have that little term
p of z here um that we we haven't talked
about usually what what uh we pick for
this is just a standard normal
distribution so that the kl divergence
is really easy between the two and in
general that doesn't lose generality for
um for the entire variation out and
cutter
and that would allow us to get to the to
the use case that we talked about where
we can have two images mapped to
different parts of the latent space and
then we can interpolate through that
latent space z and the different samples
from that space would result in
different images from our data set
all right so what does that mean exactly
that equation it looks a little
complicated so what what's going on here
so there are two terms here
there's the first term
right here
which is that expectation under q5 z
given x i so
this is expectation under our encoder so
it just tells us given the image what is
the most probable z that would have
produced that image we are trying to
reconstruct that image right we are
trying to maximize the log likelihood of
that image given
so that means that we are trying to this
is this we can call it the
reconstruction loss
and this is just trying to
encourage the distribution to describe
the input right so it will be pushing
both q of a q of z given x i and p of x
i given z
to just describe the input as well as
possible so if we just look at our q
what our q will be able to do
is
it will just try to find such a such a
code z so that the reconstruction is as
easy as possible so q is trying to help
p as much as it can
now what what can happen if we just use
that first term only is that our queue
can cheat a little bit and it can just
have a very tiny distribution basically
at dirac's delta
and say that for that particular code
this is the image right so it's a
perfect encoding but it's not
necessarily what we are looking for we
are trying to look for a distribution
that is a little bit wider so that we
can sample from it and so on
so
that that purely that encoding objective
that reconstruction loss can result in
in something that we don't necessarily
want in in a way that
in something where our variational
distribution can cheat a little bit
so instead so in addition then we
introduce this additional term the dkl
term the the cal day versions between
our
variational distribution and the prior
and this is penalizing the kl divergence
which kind of acts as a regularizer so
because our p of z is a normal
distribution with a certain variance we
are trying to make sure that the kl
divergence between our q and that normal
distribution is as small as possible so
basically that means let's keep that
variance of our variational distribution
a little bit larger so that we can
describe more input so it's a better
regularizer it prevents our q
um distribution from cheating
all right so that was a little bit of
intuition behind variational inference
are there any questions
one question that came up in the chat is
uh like how do you represent
distributions over
z and for x given z
so one choice is gaussian which is
typically the normal choice are there
other choices
yeah i in variational altercator as far
as i know people use gaussians
um
i think there's also there are other
distributions that you can use there's
one little cavea that we haven't talked
about which is how do you like propagate
through all of this and this is by using
so-called reparameterization trick and
there are certain distributions that we
know how we can do a parametrization
trick with such as gaussians it's fairly
easy and such as some discrete
distributions
um so some people use discrete
distributions there too but i think
gaussian is by far the most popular
choice
there's another question why do we
always choose the standard normal
distribution for p of z
right
so
that's um that's a little bit of a
design choice but our p of z can be
it kind of doesn't matter what it is
because our
um if we go back
a little bit here
um let me just show the pointer our p of
z can oh let me switch to this okay our
p of z can be any distribution
and then if we have a neural network
that can map from z to p of x given z
then
our neural network is expressive enough
to take a sample from any distribution
and transform it to any other
distribution we would like so it kind of
doesn't matter what p of z will choose
neural network is powerful enough to
represent anything else after that
so usually we try to pick something that
is really easy to deal with such as a
normal distribution the kl divergence is
given
and things are very well understood
because we don't really lose much
the expressiveness is still there
because our neural network will be able
to transform it into p of x given z
all right
um
so
let's go into um let's kind of put a pin
in this in variational inference we'll
get back to that um to that method but
now i would like to introduce control as
inference framework
and
this is the framework that we uh that we
briefly introduced and this is a
framework that allows us to describe a
stochastic optimal behavior so we had
the dog
the dog is trying to come to the owner
and we just don't want to have the the
only behavior being the straight line
but we also want to be able to represent
behavior that is a little bit stochastic
right
and when we deal with stochasticity uh
we usually want to introduce some random
variables and potentially a provost a
graphical model so so let's do that
so the things we know
are that there are some states and
actions that the doc can do
right so we can write a very simple um
probabilistic graphical model where
where we basically represent the
dynamics of the world and we say that
there are some states there are some
actions
and the dog can take an action in a
state and that will lead to a to a
different state
right so that just represents kind of
all the behaviors that the dog could do
and we will now represent the joint
probability distribution of all the
states and actions as p of
tau so tau represents a trajectory so
this is a probability distribution over
trajectories
and this is not really
very expressive because um oh actually
before we go there so what we what we
assume here is that uh we have the
transition model p of s prime given s
comma a right so we know how the
dynamics propagate
now this is not extremely expressive
because this just describes kind of any
behavior that the dot can do right the
dot can take any actions it will result
in next states but it doesn't really
describe the situation that we're in
right here where the doc is doing a very
specific behavior right the doc is very
intentional it has a task that that has
in mind and it's trying to reach the
owner
so we'll introduce an additional random
variable
that tries to describe this
right and this would look a little funny
this is a
a
random variable that is a binary random
variable depicted by a
script o
which stands for optimality
which is a a variable
uh that
basically represents the intentionality
of the dog right so the dog is trying to
accomplish a certain task
and uh and it's not just doing random
things
right so we'll introduce it as a binary
random variable so it can take only true
or false as its values
and if it's true that means that the dog
is trying to be as optimal as possible
and if it's false then the dog doesn't
care about the task it's just
the optimality doesn't matter to it
all right so
now we can represent the probability of
the trajectory given the fact that the
dog is trying to be optimal so given
uh that our optimality variable one
through capital t is equal to true
there was one point that is missing in
this we introduce an additional variable
uh that we assume to be know we assume
that the dog is always optimistic well
always if if we say that we have
probability of the trajectory given
though we'll assume that the o is equal
to true right so optimality dog is
trying to be optimal
but we introduced this additional random
variable and
we didn't really describe what those
connections mean right what's the
dependence of that variable on the
action in the state
so we'll also introduce this
and we'll introduce this as following
we'll say that the probability of the
dog being optimal at times the t given a
state at that time step and the action
that it took that the dog took
is equal to the exponential of the
reward at that state and the action at
that state with that action
right so the dog is basically
exponentially
um
what's the best way to describe so
basically if the
the higher the reward us we will
exponentiate this and our optimality
will be proportional to that so the
doctrine is trying to be more optimal as
it's getting more reward and that skills
exponentially
so this might seem a little funny right
now why there is an exponent here but
this is a particular design choice that
we choose so that we we arrive at the at
the algorithm we want at the end
all right so this is the graphical model
that we introduced to describe a
stochastic optimal behavior of that dog
that is intentional
um
i would like to do a little side step
and
we're dealing now with
a probabilistic graphical model that has
some variables that are observable such
as optimality and some that are not
known um and this is this looks like a
hidden markov model that we briefly
mentioned so i just wanted to do a
little recap of hidden markov models and
briefly describe how they work
so hidden markov models are models that
look like that so we have some kind of
evidence that is given to us
and there are some latent factors that
we don't get to see that we would want
to estimate we want to infer what they
are
and once one instance for this is for
example in a common filter where we are
getting some kind of measurements and
we're trying to estimate the positions
of the robot
and we know that given that we are in a
certain position we can be in the
different position next time step and we
also know that given that we are in a
certain position we should get a certain
measurement
all right so what's usually assumed to
be known here
first
we assume that we know so-called
emission probability so what's the
probability of our measurement given the
latent state
so
this is also often known as the
observation model in the common filter
we also assume that we know the
transition dynamics so we know the
probability of z k even z k minus one
and then we also assume that we know the
the initial probability distribution z1
p of z1
all right so um usually what we are
trying to do in hidden markov models is
we are trying to estimate this quantity
so what's the probability of our latent
variable at time step k given everything
that we get to see so given all the
measurements one through n
right so if we're able to estimate this
then we can do inference about any z
all right so this is the goal what we're
for our inference what we're trying to
do and there's one particular algorithm
that is that is trying to do to to to do
this
and this is a so-called forward backward
algorithm
now just very briefly tell you uh what
it's doing and then we'll use it for our
provost graphical model
all right so forward backward algorithm
consists of two steps there is the
forward step which is trying to compute
this quantity which is the probability
of our latent at time step k given all
the measurements up until that that
point so given all the measurements x
one through k minus one
and then there's a four there's a
backward algorithm that is trying to
compute kind of the opposite so it's
trying to compute the probability of our
measurements from k
through n so from now till the end
given our latent variable zk
all right
so
you might ask why why does it why does
it look like this why do we compute
these particular quantities
and
the reason is that if we are interested
in in this quantity right here p of z k
even x one through n we can show there's
a little bit of derivation here i'll
skip that but let's skip right to the
answer and we can show that that
quantity that we're interested in is
equal
um
a product of both of these probabilities
right so if we are able to do the
forward pass and the backward pass then
we will be able to find the answer to
our question that we're interested in
all right so this is a little side step
into a hidden mark of models
there's a question in the chat asking
about the arrow
between from from z to x whether it
should be
from z to x or whether it should be from
x to z
um should there be rox n
to z and
i'm not sure i understand the question
could you repeat that
so i think that they're uh you could
also speak up if you'd like i think that
they're asking in the graphics yeah
i can i can escape
so uh i want to ask if the arrow should
be x1 to z1 uh because x1 is observation
here right and
from the observation you arrive to the
latent space
c1
yeah so the i see so it's about the
direction of this error right here
yeah
yeah so in in that model the
the reasoning is following there is some
underlying state that is the true state
that gives rise to some measurement
right that's not that the measurement
gives rise to where you're at it's
rather that you are at a certain
position
and that would give rise to a certain
measurement so kind of causality works
this way rather than the other way does
that make sense
yeah it is thanks okay
great
um all right so we have our hidden
markov model
sidenote so let's try to look in
particular at the backward algorithm
and let's try to apply it to our our
case so in this case we're trying to
estimate the probability of uh of our
evidence of the things we know x k
through n given our latent at the
current time step
right so we go back to our model
here in the top right corner i described
everything we know about it
and now we will depict the well the
node's backward message is beta
beta of st comma 80 and this would be
equal
what we know from the current time step
till the end so from
small t through capital t given the
latent at the current time step sd comma
80.
so
what that what that fixes the
probability that we can be optimal at
time steps
t through capital t given that we take
action 18 state sd
right so this is our backward message
and we can go through the backward
algorithm and compute this
and um i'll i'm not going to go through
the derivation
but i'll show you the final result
and the final result looks like this
but we will arrive at the at the
recursive algorithm that starts from the
end that's actually where the backward
name comes from it's a dynamic
programming algorithm and it computes
the backward message
like this it it uses the probability of
optimality given the current state in
action and then the expectation under
the current dynamics of the
of the uh
backward message at the next time step
that is only dependent of st plus one
and here we define what that backward
message that is only
dependent on st is equal to
so basically when if you do dynamic
programming and you go backwards at this
point you would already know what that
is
and we know what that is this is given
to us
so we should be able to do the entire
backward pass using these formulas
all right so i wanted to look a little
bit closer um
at what what this actually means
so we went through this backward
algorithm for this backward pass and we
arrived at these two quantities and
they're maybe
not it's not entirely clear what what
they mean
so let's do a little assignment
and um i'll introduce a new letter dt of
st
and i'll say that this is equal to the
log of data of our backward message that
is dependent only on the state st
we know what that beta of st is we just
defined it right here we just we just
derived it right here
and then i'll introduce another letter
qt of sd comma 18. and i'll say that
this is equal to the log of the backward
message that is dependent on st and 80.
so this is what we derived right here
so you know this is kind of a random
assignment that i just made up
um let's try to run with it and
let's try to replace
that equation with that assignment and
see what we get
or actually sorry let's try to start
with this equation right there
all right so if we do that replacement
we'll end up with something that looks
like this our vt of st
is equal to the log of the integral of
the exponential of q t of st comma 80
over all the actions 80.
right
so that looks a little weird but
somewhat close to q learning where the
value function is very closely related
to the q function so if we assume that
our v is kind of like a value function
and the q is kind of like a q function
these two seem
kind of related here but we have that
little term here that is a little
complicated this log of integral of
exponential
right so so what what is that term let's
try to think a little bit about this so
let's let's try to consider a situation
where our q values are really big
right so we have really big q values so
for any different action that the value
there is really big now we will
exponentiate all of them
right
so if we exponentiate every single one
of them and these are really big values
then the difference between them will
get much much bigger
because of the exponential function
so
um if we do that then our biggest action
will be really really big
even compared to the second biggest
action
so then we'll take the integral across
all of these actions so we'll kind of
sum over all the possible actions and
that sum will be now dominated by that
by the top action right by detection by
the action that had the the biggest q
value
and then we'll take the log of all of
this
so basically if if that sum is dominated
by the exponent of the highest for the
cube function for the q value for the
highest action if we take the log of
this we are going back to the q for the
highest for the highest action
so basically we can say the following
this this log of integral of exponential
is basically a max over actions of our q
function
as q function gets bigger and bigger
right so the bigger the q is that the
more it looks like this
all right that looks somewhat familiar
now
um so let's take a look at the second
equation right so again we are we have
this equation that we got from the
backward pass then we have our
assignments that i wrote down here let's
try to transform this
and if we do this we will end up with
something that looks like this we would
have our q function of s t 80 is equal
to the reward at that time step plus the
log
of the expectation this is expectation
under dynamics of the exponential of vt
plus one of st plus one
all right so this kind of almost looks
like the belmont equation
um so let's try to make it a little bit
more into a bellman equation so
this is the expectation under our
current dynamics so let's pretend that
the dynamics are deterministic so
there's no expectation the expectation
of the constant we can remove that
so then we have the logarithm of the
exponent
right so these two cancel out and we'll
end up with for deterministic
transitions we'll end up in a um in an
equation that looks like this our q is
equal to the reward plus the value at
the next time step
all right so now this looks very
familiar
now um there's a little bit of a problem
because we just got rid of that
expectation here and there's something a
little bit off about this but we'll come
back to the stochastic case a little
later
all right but for now we we saw that
with that specific assignment we can
kind of retrieve something that looks
like a q learning algorithm where our q
is equal to the reward plus the value of
the next time step and our value is the
max over actions of the queue
right so uh
let's go one step further and so far we
just computed the backward step and we
kind of arrived at something that looks
like q learning let's try to compute the
policy
right
so with the policy we'll try to compute
the probability of action at the given
state
assuming that we are optimal
right
uh we'll depict it as pi of 80 given st
and i'll skip the derivation we apply a
bayes rule here but at the end we arrive
at something that looks like this our
policy is equal to the backward message
that is dependent on sd given 8 and 80
divided by the backward message that is
only dependent on
sd all right so let's try to put all of
this together
so
first we have the our backboard pass
formulas that look kind of like q
learning
and now we have our policy that is equal
to the ratio between these two backward
messages
now if we use our assignment that we
that we had before
we will arrive at something that looks
like this our policy
so our probability of action at a given
state
is equal to the exponential of the q and
that state for that action minus v at
that state
so this is the difference between our q
function and the value function which is
also known as the advantage function
right so now we said that our policy is
equal to the exponential of our
advantage for that specific action in
that specific state
and that seems to make sense so
basically what it says is that
the policy assuming that you're trying
to be optimal
in that probabilistic graphical model
will try to pick actions that are
exponentially more likely
or exponentially give higher advantage
right so like the higher the advantages
the exponentially more likely will be to
pick those actions
and importantly we won't be picking the
actions that are always optimal right
that we are not just taking the actions
that are doing the max over the queue
but we are doing something that is
almost like this it's a little bit
softer
right they're distributed according to
this distribution and that distribution
is very
high tightly tied to the reward but it's
not just the max
all right so this is quite a bit of math
in control as inference um strength also
to give you a little bit of intuition
but are there any questions at this
point
i did have a question about the backward
pass and in particular the
big t i didn't really understand
how this algorithm gets off the ground
running because
maybe you can just explain first what
big t is but yeah if you look at the
first
like when we first start the dynamic
algorithm
we need
some value
at t plus
yeah the first line under the for loop
like when we first start the algorithm
we have to have
the
expectation there of
beta t plus one but how do we get that
to begin with right right yeah this is
this is a great question um all right so
actually to explain this we need to go
back here so here what we would have is
we would have a note at the end
that would be
s
capital t
right
and i
believe would also have the optimality
variable
at that time step
o
at time step t
um
i believe that's the case let me think
about this
um
[Music]
yeah i think so
so i think at the very i'm not entirely
sure about this i can get back to this
for you i'm sorry
but i believe that at the very final
time step at t minus 1
this quantity here that is in question
will be equal to
um
you know so we will have the the
backward message of bt plus one of st
plus one
that bt plus one of st plus one would be
equal to something like that so the
question is basically what would that be
equal to
for the very last time step and i
believe this would be
[Music]
this would be the probability
of the optimality at the very final
times that the given state and the
action and that will be just equal to
this exponential of the reward at the
very final time step
so for the very final time step it would
just equal to this
and then we would go backward from there
i believe
but i can double check that for you
and t is in the future and it's defined
a priori
big t is in the future sorry and it's
right so t is the it's kind of the the
horizon for how long the dog will be
acting okay right so the t will be the
very final time step where the dog kind
of gets to the owner and it stops there
okay cool i think i kind of get it thank
you
all right
cool um so we talked a little bit about
control as inference now we'll
uh take the concept that we introduced
in the first part of the lecture the
variational inference and we'll try to
apply it to our problem and see where we
where we end up
all right so
we started with a graphical model that
looks like this
and we can write the joint probability
of that entire model
and what we what we know is we have the
the initial probability distribution of
the of the initial state
uh we have the transition probability
and we also have the probability of
optimality for the given state in action
this is the exponent of the reward
so
we know that our joint distribution
given that the graphical model
would would factor like this it will
factorize us like that
all right
so this is what we what we know so far
now we will try to introduce a
variational distribution so variational
distribution is a distribution over
things that we've done now that are not
visible to us so this is not our d
evidence the evidence in this case are
our optimality variables so the
variation in distribution or q of z
before has to be over the things that we
don't see
right so this would be the q of s1
through capital t comma a1 through
capital t
and we'll we'll just say that our
variational distribution is of this form
and we pick this particular graph
with with certain
goal in mind and you will see that in a
second
right so this is a graph that looks very
similar to the graph we had before
right this is very very close but it has
this one additional connection between s
and a
right and usually we try to pick
variational distributions that are very
simple
so that um every all the all the all the
equations get simpler
here we we did a we made a little bit of
an odd choice but we'll see that it will
actually um allow us to to make things
simple at the end
all right so uh let's talk a little bit
about this graph
so here we have the probability of the
of the initial state was uh is the same
as what we had before
we have transition dynamics that was
also described with the exact same
probability as before
but here we introduce an additional
connection and this is the variational
connection that we didn't have in the
previous graph and we'll call it q of a
t given st
so now we can write the entire joint
distribution for
that graphical model
and this would be equal to um
to probability of the initial state
times the product of all the transition
probabilities and our q of a t given st
so now we have our variational
distribution
and we have our original distribution
and one thing to note here is that the
variational distribution has the exact
same dynamics and the initial state as p
as our original distribution
and the only new thing
is
this variational distribution q over 80
given st right so this is this is the
choice we made for our cube
all right so now um if you remember we
were operating on x's and z's before
when we were talking about variational
inference where x's were the things that
we know and z is for the latent factors
so here we'll do assignment that looks
like this we will say that uh the things
we know are our optimality variables we
assume them to be true
and the latent factors are the all the
states in actions
so in that case
that joint probability distribution down
here is q of z
and that joint probability distribution
right here is the probability of z comma
x
right since z is everything here and x
is that part
all right so let's try to apply our
variation lower bound so this is a quick
reminder of a variation lower bound that
we had at the beginning of the lecture
let's try to apply it here so the
variation lower band looked like this we
can transform it a little bit to look
like that
all right so now we have that
log of p is lower bounded by
by this formula right here
so let's try to apply it given our
assignment that we set
right so if we do that then we have our
joint probability distribution of p of x
comma z
and we have our variation distribution q
of t or q of s1 through capital t comma
a1 through capital t
we can we will now do the assignment and
so we will say that
log probability of our optimality one
for capital t is lower bounded
by the expectation now the expectation
is under the q and our z is our joint
joint probability of all the states and
actions
and now we'll take that log of p of x
comma z
and we'll apply um
the rule that if you take the logarithm
of the product you will get some of the
of the logarithms
um
and that would look some something like
that so basically we would have here
this is we are describing the log of p
of x comma z just using our assignment
right we're just basically splitting
that product into the sum
[Music]
and now we have to subtract our log of q
of z
so let's do that
so this is our q of z
we are applying the the log rule and
we're splitting it into the sum
so now you can see that this log of p of
s1 is equal to this
this part is equal to our product of
transition dynamics and then we have one
additional term log q a t comma given st
and now you can kind of see why we made
that that odd choice at the beginning
what that allows us to do is that allows
us to cancel out the initial state
distribution as well as the dynamics
so what we end up with is something that
looks like this and in particular
something that looks like that so
our optimality the log probability of uh
optimality
is lower bounded by this objective so if
we're trying to optimize
our optimality
since this is lower bounded by this we
can instead maximize the lower bound
and that will result kind of in the same
thing so what is the lower bound here
that that lower bound says that we'll be
taking and uh will be summing over our
time steps under the expectation of our
cure of our current queue
all the rewards that we're getting at
every time step plus the entropy of the
policy q
of a t given st
right
so what that means is that
if we're trying to be optimal in order
to do this given that probabilistic
graphical model and that variational
inference we will be optimizing the
rewards but not only just the rewards
which we which is what we will do in the
standard reinforcement learning as we
will also add to that objective the
entropy of the policy so what that means
is that the policy is trying to stay as
wide as possible
right so it's trying to not be committed
to any solution it's trying to be wide
so what that translates to is that we're
trying to max maximize the reward and
maximize the action entropy
all right so to quickly summarize this
our objective from that variational
inference in this graphical model looks
like this it's the sum of the rewards
plus the entropy
then we will have we have the value and
q functions that are also derived using
the that same framework and actually if
we apply that variation inference that
we just described to our q function it
will result in something like this which
resolves our problem that we had before
that expectation right in the middle
here so this problem is gone if we if we
do this correctly
and our policy itself would be
exponential of the advantage
right
so we have kind of all the components
that we would need to construct an
algorithm now
so
if you remember the q learning algorithm
it looked like this we were collecting a
data set then we were calculating the
target values for the q function and
this was equal to the benjamin equation
so it was the reward plus the maximum of
the queue at the next time step and then
we'll trying to fit our q function to
these targets
right this is a standard q learning
algorithm and we saw an application of
this for example for qtr for robotics
and our policy was picking the max
the arg max of the queue so it was
picking the action that maximizes our q
value
right so here we derived something that
we'll call a soft q learning algorithm
since the max is not just a pure max but
it's a little bit softer we kind of
incorporate the stochasticity here
so so far i just copied everything that
we had on the left side so here are the
notifications
so the bellman equation is changed as
following instead of having the hard max
over the actions this is changed into a
soft max and soft max describes that log
of integral of the exponent
right so we are not taking the full max
but here a little bit softer here
and instead of taking the policy that is
doing the arc max over the q function
our policy is now the exponential of the
advantage right so it's not as hard as
before either
all right so we started with some
parabolic graphical model that describes
stochastic optimal behavior
and then using backward messages and um
a little bit of algebra will be the
variational inference we derived an
algorithm
that is that resembles q learning but
it's a little bit softer that kind of
takes into account the fact that we are
trying to be a little bit more
stochastic
all right so let's quickly see how this
algorithm works in practice so this
algorithm was implemented in this paper
from thomas hornoyadol
um
and just to again give a little bit more
intuition if this is the landscape of
our q function in gray here so on the y
axis we have the q value on the x-axis
is the action and the q function has
some
you know hills and valleys
usually if we're applying if we were to
apply a standard q-learning algorithm
our policy will basically focus on the
peak of that q function that will always
try to pick the max here
with soft q learning our policy is now
proportional to the exponent of the
queue or the exponent of the advantage
so it's not only trying to put all the
probability mass at the peak but it will
save a little bit of probability mass
for for other hills as well so it's not
as committed as the as the standard q
learning algorithm
right
so this is this is kind of the
motivation for it
right so um why is this useful for the
policy to not be as committed
so here are a few examples so first this
is useful for exploration so here's a
task where you have this ant like robot
and the robot starts right here and
that's trying to minimize the distance
to the gall which is that blue square
right here
now if the q learning on the left we see
the q the behavior of the
of a converged q learning algorithm
where the end just happened to explore
the path up here first and since this is
also initially getting smaller and
smaller distance it gets a little bit
stuck here and the policy is
basically like always looking for those
heal
for the for the hill in the q function
landscape so it's really difficult the
policy already is has already committed
to that solution and it's really
difficult for it to unlearn it and try
something else
on the right here we see a solution
coming from a softkey learning algorithm
where you're not as committed you you
still
have some probability mass on on actions
that might have a little bit uh
a little a little bit lower
outcome but that allows you to kind of
keep exploring different options and
eventually find the better solution to
the problem
this is also uh shown here
where
the the reward is just the speed of the
amp
and the speed can be in any direction so
basically just the the the speed
and uh on the left here we'll see what's
the
distribution of behaviors that we get if
we do a standard q learning algorithm
such as dtpg which is a specific extra
critical algorithm and what is the the
distribution of behaviors we get if we
apply soft key learning to that problem
right so let's see
so you can see that dtpg kind of seems
to be committed to one direction and it
just goes with that versus soft q
learning allows the amp to kind of
explore all kinds of different
directions and cover the state space a
little bit better because it's also
trying to optimize for that entropy of
the policy
so what that also means is that if we
were to pre-train our policy with soft q
learning it will be much easier to
fine-tune because now our ad is a little
bit more competent it can it knows how
to behave in many different condition
conditions
and lastly that also leads to more
robust policies right so here's an
example of a real robot experiments
where
the others are trying to stack these two
lego blocks
and uh
because this is trained with soft q
learning now if you perturb the robot
the policy has visited these states
because it was not trying to be very
committed and just straight optimal and
it knows what to do with them so it's a
little bit more robust if you perturb it
it can still it has it might have
experienced that state during training
because it wasn't as committed and it
knows how to get to the goal
all right so um this summarizes controls
variation inference framework and we
introduced the soft key learning
algorithm
um are there any questions at this point
oh and i think uh
it's raising your hand yeah would you
mind go then by two slides yep
yeah so just curious what is the
self-max term that you add to the to the
second line of the soft q learning
algorithm so
because you don't have access to that ai
prime that action
oh sorry so this is over all the actions
right so this the softmax term is
exactly this
right so you're taking the log of
integral across all the actions
right so before we were taking the max
over all the actions now we are taking
soft max and soft max as a term for for
this
uh little equation here a lot of
integral dx
okay thanks
yup first one question
yeah i just was wondering when we made
the assumption about the probabilistical
graphical model that enabled us to kind
of cancel out the
dynamics uh are there any practical
limitations to that like that would
limit the
learning of the algorithm
that's an interesting question so
to rephrase this question
is it possible to come up with a
different variational distribution
that will make that algorithm better
um yeah that's really interesting i'm
not sure
uh
potentially
um
i haven't thought about other
variational distributions that we could
do there um
you know there's many many different
options it just has to be any
distribution over the variables that we
don't see we're relating variables
this particular one
gives rise to this algorithm but i think
you know there are probably other
options
and that could give rise to different
algorithms
i'm not sure but this is a very
interesting
question
thanks
all right um there are no other
questions then um
let's take all of this that we that we
derived so far and let's try to
introduce a new meta reinforcement
learning algorithm using all of these
tools
all right so so far we've been
considering the dog and the owner and
the task was very clear to the dog right
the dog was trying to get to the owner
and it was getting there in a stochastic
way and we're trying to describe that
that process
so now with meta reinforcement learning
the problem setup is a little bit
different
now the dog doesn't necessarily know
what the task is
but the owner does right so the owner
has some kind of trick in mind that they
want the dog to do but the dog doesn't
know what the trick is
now the dog knows that if it does the
correct trick it will if it guesses it
right
then it would get a tree
so it's a it's a slightly different
situation
um
and my question to you is uh given that
setting was a good strategy for the dog
and you can either write in chat or you
can raise your hand
but what would you do if you're the dog
i think
you have your um hand raised i'm not
sure if this is from the previous
question but uh feel free to answer if
you have do you have any ideas see
that's from the previous one i think i
missed the question actually but i think
if the dog is being ordered to sit right
he thinks that the other person wants
him to sit then he should sit
all right
yeah so the dog doesn't necessarily know
what the owner wants from him
right it's trying to guess so but it
can't i guess uh we can assume that
maybe the dog can think that maybe the
owner is maybe the dog can try to guess
what the owner wants for example maybe
the owner wants him to sit and it should
then just sit so it should just try
something in i think that's a really
good strategy
learn to follow different directions of
the owner right so if it could
understand the directions of the of the
owner then it should just you know try
to try to follow those
but um let's assume that the
the owner can't communicate with the dog
right the owner has just something in
mind
okay try everything equal probability
yeah i think that's a really good
strategy too yeah so just guess what the
owner has in mind and just go for it and
try it and if you get a treat good for
you if you don't you will just you know
take a step back and try something else
and go for it and try that
that other idea that you have until you
get the
tree all right and believe it or not
that this is connected to
our variational inference framework so
we'll talk about that
all right so before we have the problem
graphical model that looks like this
and that describes this situation where
the doc knows what to do
the dog knows what the task is
so now we'll introduce an additional
um random variable that describes a
situation where the dog doesn't know
what the task is
so we'll introduce an additional latent
variable z which describes the task
right and this is not observed this is
not part of the evidence
now our z um our optimality will depend
on this whether you get the treat or not
depends on what task you have in mind
and because we introduced this c in the
original graphical model we also have to
introduce it in the in our variational
distribution so now our policy will be
also dependent on z so depending on what
you think the owner wants
you'll be trying very different actions
right for example if you think that the
dog that the owner wants you to sit you
will try to sit
all right so z in this case corresponds
to that latent task that the owner has
in mind
so we changed our probabilistic
graphical model a little bit to describe
that that situation
all right so we have that that
additional z what will we do
well we'll apply variational inference
again
right this is the tool that we know how
to use let's let's try to use it
in this case we'll change it a little
bit so before we had access as the
evidence so as our optimality variables
and these were
on the trajectory so all the states and
actions
i'll change it a little bit and say that
x's are still the optimality variables
but z is the latent task
and then we had our variation lower
bound that we direct at the beginning
so now let's use that assignment and see
how this will change so
what will happen is uh
here instead of x i will have the log
probability of the optimality and for
now i left the q untouched but i just
changed log of p of x i given z the log
of p
log of probability of the optimality one
for capital t given z so z in this case
describes the latent task
[Music]
so that's the only thing i did let's
let's look a little bit further what
what is this term and so this is the
probability of optimality given that
you're in a specific task
so we know from the the previous section
that the lock probability of optimality
is lower bounded by by this by this
objective where we are maximizing the
reward plus the entropy of our policy
so now this is now conditioned on z so
we'll change that formula a little bit
and we we could go through the entire
derivation but i'll just show you what
the result is so now the log of p of 01
through capital t given z
will be equal to
still the sum over all the time steps
now our variational distribution is not
only over s st and 80 but also over z so
we'll change that
the reward will depend on the task z as
well
and our entropy will be on the
of the policy that is also dependent on
z so the policy works differently
depending on differences
so it's very similar formula we had
before we didn't go for the whole
derivation but it works basically almost
exactly the same
all right
so we have
the other term left which is the q of z
of our task given x i right so in this
case our x i technically should be the
optimality variables but they're not
really telling because these optimality
variables are always true
and if you remember we can pick the
variational distribution to be
conditioned on anything we like
okay this is our our design choice
and we we would want to pick the the
thing that this that our variation
distribution should be conditioned on
such that it's very easy to guess what
task it is
and so the question is what's a good x i
in this case what should we condition
our variational distribution on so that
we can easily guess what the task is
so in this case one thing we can try is
just to transition in all the
transitions that we have seen so far
so basically the dog is trying different
tricks
and we'll try to guess what task it is
even everything that the doc has done so
far right so if it's tried sitting and
it didn't get any rewards we'll
incorporate that into its into its
thinking if it's right then
jumping or shaking or something it will
also incorporate this it will
incorporate everything it's ever done
and the rewards associated with those
behaviors
all right
so um this is the main idea behind per
uh parallel algorithm and this is a way
to derive it using probabilistic
graphical model and i think if you've
heard about this algorithm before so
i'll just quickly give you the intuition
of how this works with with this
graphical model so this is worked by
catering at all
so
apparel is an um off policy meta
reinforcement algorithm that works like
this we would have some kind of
adaptation data so this is a dog trying
different things
and collecting all the transitions so
that they're trying to sit trying to
jump trying all kinds of different
things
and in this paper they refer to this as
context c so c in this case are all the
transitions that you've seen so far
right
and then we'll have our variational
distribution where we're trying to guess
what task it is so this is the
probability of the task of z given all
the history so far or given our context
so this is basically
this distribution right here our q of z
even x i where x is the context c
right so we'll take the adaptation data
we'll take everything we've seen so far
and we'll try to guess what's the most
likely z
um that would explain that that that
would explain the data
and then we will pretend that this is
the task that the owner wants
so we'll guess our best z will pretend
that this is the task that the owner has
in mind and then we'll try to optimize
our queue function with that task uh in
mind so we'll try to optimize um as if
this was the task so it's basically
equivalent to the dock trying to guess
what is the task that the the owner has
in mind and just going for it
so if you look at the objective that um
the address writings paper
it looks exactly the same as the
objective that we wrote in the previous
slide with variational inference so this
is the objective where you take the
expectation under
our q5 of z given given the context so
given all the transitions
here we have the reward and this is
actually a soft reward so this is using
the reward plus the entropy
and we have the kl divergence term that
tries to keep this distribution our
variational distribution close to a
normal gaussian so um so that we we have
that regularization term that comes from
variational inference
and then because this is we can do all
of this using off policy reinforcement
we can optimize for this reward using
our soft queue functions and so on uh
this is an algorithm that can be run off
policy and because of this it's much
more efficient than um many other on
policy equivalents such as rl square rl
squared mammal or paramp
and this is what you see in these graphs
here so it works really really well
all right so um
just i just wanted to reiterate this
that the intuition behind us so if you
remember we were talking about
the dog that
that knows that if it does the right
thing it will get a treat but it doesn't
know what it is that the owner has in
mind will just commit and try and based
on the things that sees it will finally
it will eventually figure out what the
task is and do that
so it turns out that the
the behavior that pearl exhibits is very
similar to this so here's a task that
was given to it so we start at that at
the race circle circle down here
and then the only thing we know is that
there is a reward somewhere on that
circle
but the algorithm doesn't know where it
is
right and what you see here what are
these uh these lines is the trajectories
that the pearl tries that the pearl
algorithm tries to do so at first just
randomly tries and tries to commit to
um you know a specific goal that that it
thinks maybe the the designer has in
mind and then it tries it a few times
until and the the blue circle depicts
the actual reward that's not visible to
the parallel algorithm and then it
finally samples the execution of the
test that corresponds to it and then it
narrows it down and knows what task it
does
and that procedure is also called
posterior sampling since we are using
posterior uh belief to sample what the
test gets
so it behaves very similarly to what we
what we described as a good strategy for
the dog
all right so that summarizes uh meta rel
as variational inference are there any
questions yeah
right um
do you think there is there are better
strategies for the doc or for pearl
algorithm for this specific task
other than sampling a specific task and
going for it
can you do can you do something better
knowing that there is a reward on the
circle
anywhere on the circle
[Music]
i think we saw an example where you
could like go out to the ark and then
uh track it so that you're guaranteed to
find it in like one trajectory yeah yeah
exactly so posterior sampling might not
be the best solution here um and there
are other papers that
do it differently um yeah so it's
important too to keep that in mind
um right cool so um
that um that summarizes the
the lecture where we learned a lot about
variational inference then we presented
the framework that allows us to phrase a
controller reinforcement learning
problem as an inference problem and that
has many other applications that we
haven't talked about but a lot of papers
use that
that correspondence then we applied
variationally inference to that problem
and saw how we can
derive an algorithm by using that
and then using that framework by a
simple addition of an additional latent
variable that is not not visible to us
that the task we arrived at the meta
reinforcements algorithm that can do
that can use of policy learning and then
produces state-of-the-art results
all right so um as for next week um
we'll try to answer additional questions
that um
come to mind when you when you think
about these problems
such as
what what what should we do if we want
the agent to come up with their own
tasks but if we don't want to specify
the task and we just want to leave the
agent unattended
and have them figure out all the useful
tasks
how should we think about hierarchies of
and then can the agent learn
continuously over their lifetime so how
can we produce an agent that not only
comes up with its own task it can build
its own hierarchies but also can kind of
do it over the course of its entire life
and next week we'll talk about the uh on
monday we'll talk about the first two
topics and then wednesday we'll talk
about the the last one
um there's a few additional resources
that i encourage you to take a look at
um first there's this uh really good
tutorial written by sergey 11 on
control as inference
um if you'd like to learn a little bit
more about pearl there is this
quite
nicely and simply written their blog
post about it
and then there's also the berkeley deep
reinforcement learning course that also
has classes on control as inference
all right and
this is it thank you so much and if
there are any other questions i will
stick around so uh
please uh just ask
uh one quick question so
the
um kind of additional target of
optimizing for the entropy
of the policy reminded me of
like
epsilon
and like adding a little bit of
probability for your model uh like the
policy
and i was wondering like how those
compare in terms of performance or in
terms of theory yeah yeah that's a
that's a really good question um
yeah so epsilon greedy is kind of like a
little heuristic that people came up
with to encourage a little bit more
exploration
here we kind of derived a more
principled way to do this
um in a way that it's not just that
we'll try random things from time to
time but we'll try to keep the
distribution very wide so we'll allow
the agent to kind of incorporate that
into its own objective it's not that we
are altering the algorithm by
incorporating that little heuristic but
we we tell the agent up front that we
want you to be not as committed as you
would have been
i think in terms of how they compare
i believe that the state-of-the-art dprl
algorithms use these soft objectives so
things such as subtactor critic i think
are still one of the best rl algorithms
out there
and they um
they use the soft objective that that
incorporates the entropy and it's also
um
um sometimes what people do is they will
still incorporate the epsilon greedy
even to the soft objective right so so
that heuristic kind of works regardless
where you apply it so you can you can do
both as well
that's it thanks
right